let's start with the leisurely 15 plus
10.
let's go e4 thank you once again i'm
going to mute the alerts
during the speed run because this will
be going on youtube but that doesn't
mean i don't appreciate
the gifts
[Music]
okay so what opening shall we play we
can play an italian we can play right
lopez
uh let's play an italian now the italian
is like a light
is like a rite of passage right it's the
opening that a lot of beginners play but
not a lot of people know how to play it
properly when you play the italian
properly it becomes
far from just like a boring
run-of-the-mill opening into something
that's actually super dangerous
what do you guys say shall we play the
fried lover
let's play the fred liver now this is
the fried lever as you guys know i've
shown many times okay bishop c5 is the
traxler
okay listen up guys the traxler
developed by czech player carol traxler
as i explained to charlie
the whole idea here is that knight takes
f7 to the untrained eye looks like it
wins the game
you guys might be looking at this those
of you who don't play e4 wait a minute
knight f7 that forks the queen and the
rook what am i missing here queen has to
move
we take the rook i'm up a full rook okay
maybe he wins the night in the end but
still it'd be up in exchange
but there is a detail um and the key
detail to
understand is that after knight f7 black
has a crazy counter sacrifice bishop
takes f2 check
and um one second i'm writing down the
game label
straw man
with white so traxler and after the game
i will explain how exactly this line
sort of works how should we res how
should we react to the track sir
white's best move here is actually super
anti-climactic
what can we do except knight takes f7 is
is there an alternative that
maybe is not so sexy on the surface but
also seems pretty good
and doesn't allow bishop takes f2 yeah
bishop f7
we just stick with the bishop obviously
he can't take on f2 he's in check
so we simply take with the bishop and
then we make another very anticlimactic
move
now if we were to simply develop notice
that the bishop is a type 2 undefended
piece he would play h6 he would chase
the knight away
we'd be in trouble so what what do we do
to avoid trouble
yeah there should be three we bring the
bishop onto a defended square he goes
king back to e8
now obviously again knight f7 would
basically transpose into the traxler
so we just castle we're up upon we've
uh killed his castling rights and
there isn't a single shred of attacking
chances for black now that we've castled
and now we're just going to play d3
cement the pawn and now we are
threatening that f7 again
key piece of advice uh just because a
move doesn't work in one position
doesn't mean you need to bury that move
entirely
tons of blunders happen because of this
at every level
knight f7 doesn't work in one position
okay i would not resign if i were you uh
because i don't mean to preach but it is
a chance to learn
so even if you're you feel like you're
losing you know unless you're completely
losing feel free to continue i won't
judge you
but i i do suppose this gives me a
chance to show the traxler
which i myself don't know that well but
bishop takes f2 is the key idea maybe
somebody more knowledgeable and the
traxxar can help me out
now the idea is a simple uh you know
decoy sacrifice right no actually not a
decoy sacrifice it like
draws the king after you're luring the
king and now knight takes c4 comes in
and again it might not seem like black
has very much
but after one of these moves like all of
a sudden black is threatening checkmate
black has managed to evade sort of the
fork the rook is now free to move
because
well because of white must attend to the
threat of checkmate
and uh i won't go into the the sort of
you know the dirty details but
i believe the black is actually fine in
the track that i think with best play
the game should end in a draw
so to be completely honest um
you know this is just not worth going
into bishop f7 is much simpler it
refutes the track star
black simply has nothing because if you
compare this
the knight on g5 is fulfilling a key
defensive role it is defending e4
so knight e4 if you play as if you did
in the track so you just give up the
knight
okay now the best response to the fried
lever in my opinion
you should play sound openings even if
the trappy opening is very tempting and
that is the move d5
as i explained to mr lama knight takes
d5
is very famously refuted by knight takes
f7 this sacrifice
so what is the best move in this
position
what is the best move in this position
and then we'll begin the next game and
that is knight a5
you move the knight away and this is
also a very well known line black
actually does sacrifice upon this is a
gambit
you can think of this as a gambit and in
return for the game but black gets a
very big initiative he starts pushing
white's pieces around he's got a big
center
and uh this gets very very complicated
so again
the emphasis of the speedo games is not
on the opening that's a little bit of an
overview
again in this position i would say that
black is much much worse black is not
losing
after rook f8 i can't fork him so
black is quote-unquote only down a pawn
of course he can't castle
it's kind of miserable but nonetheless
try to continue playing try to be
resilient
any questions
how do you play fico's queen f3 in which
position
uh can you be more specific in which
position ak
not sure where your
where in which position you're thinking
about queen f3 yeah i mean here queen f3
doesn't actually do anything
all right guys it's hard for me to
interpret some of these questions if
you're not
if you don't refer to a specific move
owner well the tracks are
bad that's the whole point the traxler
is bad if white knows to take on f7 of
the bishop
so what i'm saying is if you want to
play the soundly you should play d5 the
tracks are
relies on white taking on f7 with the
knight which a lot of people will do
automatically so the question oh right
oh in the end
well queen f3 isn't actually threatening
anything it's actually walking into an
x-ray
now i'm not saying you should move the
knight maybe black should just develop
his pieces
maybe get the bishop out so i don't
think that this is
particularly particularly a dangerous
move
also you can play knight t4 as someone
indicated just chase the queen away
that's actually a very typical response
to queen f3 in the opening
is is knight to d4 or knight to d5 okay
um who is veal hayes
vil hayes can you announce yourself in
the chat 1658
bill hayes
okay let's play bill hayes all right
let's play e4 again this one is a 10
minute game
10 plus five let's continue
and um
what opening have i been playing against
the sicilian pretty consistently and i
will continue to do that
because what i want to do is emphasize
and i know this might be boring to some
of you i know you want to see a lot of
different opinions trust me i know that
but but the point of the speedrun and i
will eventually branch
out but i really want to take a couple
of key concepts and
really work on them and it's more
conducive i think to play a relatively
narrow set of openings
in order to do that because again the
focus isn't really on openings maybe it
will be one day
okay so d5 is correct and this is
actually main line theory we go d4 can
test the center
just to remind you guys the way that you
understand this queen to be good
is with the fact that the knight can't
come to c3 if the knight can come to c3
the queen on d5 is usually bad that's
like the dividing line
and so black doesn't need to worry about
moving the queen away from the center
uh black's best move is simply to
develop the knight and put pressure on
the pawn
but in this context you can also
understand why this move
is actually inaccurate who can explain
to me why this move is inaccurate in in
the context of what i just said
yeah that's exactly right king sack i
mean easy question yeah so it opens up
it opens up the c3 square for the night
which makes the queen a lot less stable
right so so this and i talk about this a
lot at this level 1600 a lot of players
have the tendency to
to release the tension by which i mean
if there is a trade
they'll go for the trade if there is a
capture you'll go for the capture you
want clarity in the position which is
completely understandable that's like a
human
it's human nature but sometimes you have
to resist the temptation to clarify the
position
uh because you give your opponent
certain advantages
that you know that you had no need to
give him
now it doesn't it might not immediately
appear to be bad because of this move
but here white has a very nice trick
and that trick is to play bishop to e2
now you might look at this and say wait
a minute
he can just take the pawn and then he
can take sorry you can take the knight
and then take the pawn
and black wins upon who can tell me why
and maybe he'll do this i don't think so
why is this
not representative of the whole story
because the queen is then a type 2
undefended piece it's protected only by
the nine guess what
that bishop would just appeared on f3
can take the knight with check
and win the queen i'll show you guys a
game that i played in a different
opening where i did just that
okay now we reap the fruits of our
newfound ability to develop the knight
to c3 dislodging the queen from d5
now black actually yeah so this is this
may look
fancy but it's not actually that good
because here's the thing what should
white do
here should we go bishop d2 to get rid
of the pin
or is there a more harmonious way
to get rid of the pin yeah we should use
castle right bishop d2 is a very passive
move there's no need to play it
and here's the thing he can take on c3
and maintain his queen on d5
but the medicine is almost worse than
the cure
because if we consider the implications
of this trait
let's reason logically what does white
get
as a consequence of the straight
assuming that he does take on c3
there's a couple of things that he gives
me if he takes the knight which are all
in white's favor
well the first is the central pawns
right we no longer have an isolated pawn
it's now protected by its neighbor
we get the two bishops we get the p-file
we get the ability
to develop this light square of the star
squared bishop to a3
and if he doesn't castle in time which
is very likely because he still needs to
develop this knight he's gonna have a
very hard time getting castled
so he decides to get his queen back to
d7 but that's a pretty serious
concession as well that's what we wanted
now um we need to strike while the iron
is hot what i'm noticing here is that he
hasn't developed his night yet he's not
even close to castling which signals to
me that if i were to open up the center
black might have a very bad time here uh
trying to manage with this king in the
center but as long as the e file remains
closed
the king remains relatively safe so the
very thematic move d5 comes to mind
yeah those are considered hanging pawns
to be neutron
that's actually exactly what hanging
pawns are they're the bnc pawns which
are
themselves upon island
so does this make sense if he takes on
d5 we take with the knight
the knight is defended by the queen so
he can't capture the knight
and notice that i made this move really
without calculating it's it's a very
thematic move
and normally i would actually try to
calculate the implications but here
the concepts are so clearly defined that
i'm allowing myself to make this move
without calculating okay bishop c3
let's unpack this move for a second what
does he want well if we were just to
blindly take that
bishop then he can now take the pawn we
no longer have a knight
that defends the pawn but i first i
anticipated this
and we have a simple response
because when a capture is made we need
to resist the temptation to recapture
automatically consider the other options
if we consider the other options we see
that we can actually take his knight
and this position isn't as complicated
as it appears what is hanging
his queen is hanging his bishop is
saying that means he must take our queen
or he loses either his queen or his
bishop
and after we recapture his queen once
again
there are two things which are hanging
the first is the bishop the second is
this pawn
that's not just any pawn though that's
the b7 pawn
if we get a pawn on b7 that's going to
be a monster we're basically going to
promote
and what i want you guys to understand
is that even though it's now
quote-unquote and end game the fact that
he hasn't developed his king side is
going to hurt him
even more because he's not going to have
the firepower to
contain that pawn on b7 so he has to
choose
between losing a piece in the end game
disaster or giving might be upon on b7
disaster
the game is essentially over if we can
play carefully
okay now one of the key mistakes that
people make in positions like these
is they sort of take their foot off the
gas pedal they relax and they get let
their opponent back in the game
let's begin by creating a wish list okay
hey likewise what is the ideal
scenario like what do we want to
accomplish
in the ideal case can you guys describe
to me like what is the ultimate goal
here
concerning the pawn on b7 okay
the ultimate goal is to queen the pawn
but in order to clean the pawn
we need to get the stroke out of b8 so
the ultimate goal
is to get the rook out of b8 now what's
stopping us from going bishop f4
so what's stopping us from dislodging
the rope immediately
well the fact of the matter is right
he's actually threatening to capture the
pawn
so let's find a way to defend the spawn
but preferably let's do it with tempo
a lot of you guys will be tempted to
play bishop a6
and rightly so because bishop a6 is just
crashing we could have also given a
check on b5
but no need to experiment now the other
thing people don't do is they
they focus only on one way of
accomplishing something without
taking the time to consider all of the
ways of accomplishing that thing so
for example what is black's best move
here how does black prevent us from
going bishop to f4
how does black prevent us from going
bishop to f4
well e5 is yeah so e5 is one possibility
but bishop c7 seems to be the most
robust
and after bishop c7 there's no point in
despairing ah you can't get our bishop
therefore
what can we do okay he allows bishop f4
this just wins on the spot
what could we have done yeah bishop v3
min
you're pretty good player but i'll show
that after the game
one moment i'm writing something down
this is over he has to move his rope
then we promote the pawn
oh yeah this move
okay so
let's make a five-head move obviously
taking on b8 is good
there's no doubt about that and um you
know what
let's not make a five-head move let's
make a five foot move by taking
now we're going to make a five head move
we do not need to move the bishop
could somebody propose an alternative to
moving the arrow kc1
you guys this is like second a to rook
c8 rook hey
obviously if he takes the bishop we win
his rook we win the game
we can basically pre-move roxy i mean it
doesn't matter what he does
we are simply going to put the rook on
on c not on c7 don't see it
and it's goodbye because if he goes
rookie to e8
he tries to keep his rook on the eighth
rank
we can poke and prod at that rook
we have some cool ideas here let's see
if he allows us to demonstrate it
okay hey nemsco what's up
hey you good to see you how do we get
this rook out of e8
and now i'm gonna play something in
nemesco's honor let's play something
cool here bishop b5
we continue to move his rook right if he
takes on ca we make a queen
his only move to my understanding is
rook to f8 there's no other square along
the eighth rank
that is feasible for the rook um
so if he goes rook to d8 then we we take
okay and now we have a really cool move
eric gifting us up to
slizzle see
rook d7 beautiful rook d7 check
we force the knight out of there and now
finally the red carpet has been unrolled
the pawn
is going to promote if he takes the
bishop we can actually take the rook
first we don't need to promote and let
him take
the game is over
resign time
yeah that was a nice game and he's doing
whatever i'm saying no i mean the game
is over
it's okay i mean i trust that most
people are honorable
but it doesn't matter because it's over
you cannot stop my pawn from promoting
good game
okay
i'm just curious i'm going to flex on
you guys
i'm curious i like to see you know
before i delve into the analysis if i
made any serious mistakes
come on finish that report nice
i won't flex that but that was a pretty
pretty high accuracy
okay so let's unpack
now this is a very common uh no there cd
is not a mistake per se if black follows
up very precisely
um flex is right
i'm just a perpetual flexor basically
cd is not a mistake if black plays very
accurately but for the purposes of like
practical play it is a mistake
so once again just to remind you this
opens up the c3 square for the knight
and that's the ultimate error in this
move so what should black do instead
black should basically do the same exact
thing he did
just without cd because
in this position you know black can play
e6 or black can play knight f6
and and we don't have this key move
knight c3 so white can play knight a3
and try to get the knight to b5 but
that's
quite a bit less scary holy smokes
nine hours that's quite a bit less scary
than
than allowing knight c3 okay
um so so cd cd knight c6 knight f3
bishop g4 but should be doing that this
is a very important principle
uh when you have an isolated pawn it is
very helpful to know this tech
to know this trick which is you can
unpin yourself in this precise way and
the point the point is that here you
don't actually lose the pawn
because you notice that the knight is
defending the queen we can capture the
knight with check that's equally
important
the fact that it's with check otherwise
he would have taken up queen
now we take on d4 and the game is over
we are up a queen a couple of years ago
i had
a game that went precisely in this way
not from this opening but the technique
of me
winning the game was entirely the same
let me show you guys very quickly
my opponent was you know carl is is is
actually
underrated but this was not his game now
this was a completely unrelated opening
king's indian attack
kind of a catalan and
i used a very similar technique now the
like again the type of position is
different the technique is the same
white to play he thought he won a pawn
here
but what did i do
and this is actually a pretty vicious
trap who can find the move here
yeah knight takes d4 same principle
right
and here he realized that if he takes we
slice off the defender
and we win the queen so he ended up
going queen c5 but now i just
converged on him and won very easily
because
this was like the critical moment this
early in the game yeah that's his
brother so e takes d5 would be much
better
but but this can be hard to see if
you're just if you're not used to this
concept thank you squad goblin
for the five months and uh we better go
back to the speed run
so that's that's a key concept now he
doesn't do it he goes e6 knight c3
bishop before castles
now the next key moment occurred here if
he takes on c3
then just to recap right first of all
the d4 pawn
is no longer that weak it's protected by
c3
that's number one number two
we get the b file for our rook we can go
rook b1 and attack is pawn
number three we can get our bishop out
to a3 and we can prevent him from
castling right he cannot castle
you can't move through a square that's
protected by a piece
so all of these things that we get and
if we wanted to dislodge the queen we
could go c4 we could go c4 and get rid
of the queen
so he goes queen d7 now we strike with
d5 and of course he takes d5 was
essentially forced but um this position
is pretty miserable
now i do think that black is a pretty
good chance of surviving this
just getting the night out and castling
really quickly but
boy is this going to be scary i mean
rookie one sets up
an x-ray and you know white has a whole
bunch of ideas here i'm not going to
you know queen a4 computers move is
queen a4 no it's like much better for
white actually because
if white plays precise oh that's really
that's really beautiful what is the idea
of this move what is the hidden idea of
this move
white's a plan when
oh that's a very cool concept
well i'm playing rapid rather than blitz
right now knight b6 yeah
fork and because of the x-ray this is a
full-fledged fork that is a very cool
idea
see that's something that it would take
a couple of minutes to find
dang girl that's pretty cool okay
so that's uh that would have been very
strong
dc and um
this of course is already completely
winning because if he doesn't take the
queen then we take his bishop and we win
and if he does then cb bishop a6
defending the pawn preparing bishop f4
the one key thing was after bishop c7 we
go bishop out to e3
and now we are basically targeting two
different things at once
so he just cannot hold everything
together he either has to allow bishop
takes a7 or allow bishop f4
okay so the game is over after bishop f4
we go bishop b8 rook c1
get the rook into the game and uh
basically get the get rid of the knight
forcibly because if he moves his king he
loses the rook
so now the game is over because if he
takes then we take the rook if he
doesn't take
we promote the pawn with a queen if he
goes bishop c7 then we just take
one c7 okay adan says what if f6
again uh you guys will have to be
specific because i go relatively fast
so at which point
at which point can you go f65
you mean in the opening if you can be
more
a little bit more specific please
to stop bishop f4 oh good question
yeah so what if he goes f6 um
that's probably the best move but
it's not going to help in the grand
scheme of things one thing that white
can do in the name of flexibility
is we can go bishop e3 bishop b6 is four
so now we can just go rook c1
i mean look at the just look at the
position you know white doesn't even
need to go bishop f4
uh you can play this in a very simple
fashion and just say
all right i'm just going to activate my
pieces so first of all you could give
this check on c8
and here's one very nice idea
if you take on c8 then at the end of the
day white's going to be up a piece right
so the king must move aside now which
rook should we take
should just intuitively and we can take
either rook it doesn't matter
but just from a purely logical
perspective which rook should we take
so we can take the a truck right exactly
because we want to move the rook away
from its
blockade of the pawn and now who can
find
the key winning idea because without
this idea black actually
kind of holds on for the time being of
course white is winning anyway
but the key idea is to find a way to
intercept
the rook's control of the b8 square this
is what can be trouble so now bishop f4
meets with e5 that was the idea of f6
rook d7 is good but i'm looking i'm
looking very specifically for this idea
ryan has found it
ryan l is boyd yeah a lot of people want
to go here but
i would argue that while this is a good
move as a standalone move you're not
actually preparing to promote
so the move is rook c1
and the idea is to go rook c8
and notice that the bishop and the pawn
are both actually contesting the same
square
that c8 square is the key to victory it
doesn't matter what black does black can
have his rook here
black can have his rook here it it
doesn't matter
because if knight takes c8 well here we
can actually oh no that's not what we do
we can make a queen but the bottom line
is we can just take
and a lot of people what they miss is
the fact that the bishop also controls
ca remember
the concept of the x-ray if if a bishop
control
bishop can control a square without
physically controlling it for the time
being
um it's like recursion in computer
science i mean i don't know what to
compare it to
to help people see it better but it's
almost like you're
you know
you're you're just piling up on someone
right you're okay tug of war
you're playing a tug of war game you
might think okay there's like
one person two people are playing tug of
war
um but there's one person that's pushing
one of the other people to his side that
other person is indirectly influencing
growth
this bishop is pushing the pawn i don't
know
it's not a great analogy but i think you
get the point don't miss these x-rays
that's
going to say get you a lot of points
it's like this guy's brother standing
behind him
george arlo would be proud of that one
anyways that would be one way to win
so the key here is be flexible
if your main idea is stopped don't panic
just throw your hands up and ah i can't
play bishop f4
okay so i'm lost just look at the
position with a fresh pair of eyes all
right
how else can i get this rock out of b8
oh wait a minute
let me try to get the rook to c8 okay
your opponent foils the first attempt
but wait a second i have another rook
i can get the other rook to see it you
think logically you don't panic
and you exhibit maximum flexibility in
your thinking process
combination of those things yields a
very good plane
what was i worried about exactly
okay um any questions
yeah so if you took the other rook in
this specific instance that would also
be fine
because rook c8 is still a deadly threat
and there's still nothing that can be
done about it
so but in normally you know maybe black
would have had in another
reality a way to apply pressure on the
pawn on b7 if that makes sense
yeah discover defense that's a pretty
interesting concept all right guys
i think this is a good spot to pause um
i do want to
keep getting enough sleep and i have a
pretty early start tomorrow
so i hope you enjoyed these couple of
games i know that was a relatively short
session but
i am feeling pretty tired and uh we had
a lot of blitz earlier today